Nos piden graficar la desigualdad
"y" es menor que "3x" más 5
ok, entonces, si nos dan una "x"
y déjenme etiquetar aquí los ejes,
este es el eje "x" y este es el eje "y".
Entonces si nos dan alguna "x"
digamos que "x" es igual a 1
justo aquí...
entonces 3 por "x" más 5 sería
3 por 1 más 5 que es 8
¿verdad? entonces subimos
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 y 8
Entonces esto me está diciendo que
"y" debe ser menor que 8
que es 3 por 1 más 5 ¿verdad?
así que los valores de "y" que satisfacen esta
restricción para la "x"
son todos estos de aquí abajo...
déjenme hacerlo en un color más...
más clarito muy bien...
entonces para "x" igual a 1
serían todos estos valores de aquí abajo
sin incluir "y" igual a 8 ¿verdad?
porque tiene que ser menor estricto que 8.
Ahora, si seguimos haciendo esto esencialmente
vamos a graficar la línea
"y" igual a "3x" más 5,
sin incluir la línea
podríamos incluir todo lo demás debajo de
ella como lo hicimos en este punto
pero no la línea,
así que ya sabemos cómo graficar esto...
déjenme escribirlo por aquí...
así que si vamos a graficar
"y" igual a 3 "x" más 5
entonces decimos la pendiente es 3,
y la ordenada al origen es 5
es decir,
el punto donde se intersecta con el eje "y"
entonces para graficar eso simplemente
vamos a empezar
graficándolo como una línea punteada
y empezamos con la intersección
en el eje "y" que es aquí
esta es la intersección con el eje "y"
y la pendiente es 3
así que subimos por cada 1 de "x" 3 de "y"
entonces, más o menos, se vería algo así...
algo así...
estos puntos estarían en la línea ¿ok?
entonces si nos vamos para acá atrás
agregamos estos puntos
este punto y este punto
ok, y los conectamos ahora
con una línea punteada
Así que esta, esta línea punteada es la gráfica de
"y" igual a "3x" más 5
pero no la vamos a incluir
¿ok? por eso la pusimos de forma punteada.
Ahora, cualquier...
para cualquier otro "x"
digamos para "x" igual a -1
si evaluamos "3x" más 5 en esa "x"
bueno, solo nos fijamos en las
"y" que son estrictamente menor,
a ese valor que obtuvimos de "y"
entonces son todos los que están debajo de la línea,
para cualquier "x" que tomemos
todo lo que está debajo de la línea
es parte de la solución
toda esta área...
déjenme...
déjenme dibujarlo con un color más...
oscuro
entonces vamos a iluminar toda el
área debajo de esta línea.
Toda esta, entonces toda esta área es
"y" menor que "3x" más 5.